I think people would get back.
I think that the step of coming in from the period we were...
...with the fear and anxiety, and so on.
Going back is just a difficult step.
But if we would get people to do it, for even a month or two,...
...I think people would be very, very different on the end of the experience.
And we're talking about something that has taken a tremendous amount of time.
And people don't have really good intuition now about this transition...
...from this period to the next period.
We need to try it out.
And lots of things are standing in the way, it's frightening, it's effortful,...
...we get used to doing what we,...
...look people did not stand there and have empty time...
...people filled the time in different ways.
Now, they have to give up something.
So, it will need adjustment.
The people who did not work will need will need adjustment,...
...but they need to try it out.
One thing that I am predicting is that people don't understand...
...how much they miss other people.
I think we forget the joys that we have from other people.